اتخذت مواقف متوازيه تجاه الازمه في
اوكرانيا والتي اصبحت نتيجه للازمه التي
تعم
الغرب الجماعي لقد شرحنا كل
الاسباب التي
شكلت هذه الاوضاع الحاليه ونحن ندرك
اهميه العلاقات مع دول اسيا وافريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه والتعاون في شتى
المجالات ونحن نعزز الشراكه والتعاون مع
الصين فان العلاقات مع الصين هي الافضل في
تاريخ دولتين وهي تتطور باضطراد
وخاصه ان هناك
[موسيقى]
ايضا تطور في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه والشراكه مع الهند اض الى
ذلك مع
الدول في شرق اسيا بما في ذلك مجموعه
اسيان
وهناك تعاون مع معظم دول اسيا واذكر هنا
ايران
سريلانكا باكستان وغيرها من الدول
هنا ان اذكر كذلك في العلاقات الروسيه
الافريقيه التي قد وصلت الى مستويات جديده
ونحن
نعمل على تنظيم القمه الثانيه روسيا
افريقيا التي ستجري في يوليو
وان التعاون بين
بلدينا سيعزز كذلك من خلال
منتدى
البرلمانيين الذي سيجري في
اذار من هذا العام كذلك يخطط باجراء
المنتدى الاقتصادي الثاني روسيا افريقيا
ودون اي شك فعلى اساس
التعاون نعزز التنسيق بين
روسيا ودولنا
وسوف نكون مستعدين
لاستقبال الوفود الافريقيه
هنا لدينا وخاصه من وزارات الخارجيه
لدينا خطط في هذا المجال
اضافه الى ذلك
مشاهدينا كنا معكم في متابعه لجزء من هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الذي اشار فيه الى العلاقات الروسيه
الصينيه وقال انها الافضل وتتطور باستمرار
تحدث ايضا وزير خارجيه روسيا عن علاقات
بلاده مع الهند وايران وسريلانكا ومجموعات
اسيا وقال ايضا ان العلاقات مع افريقيا
وصلت لمستوى جديد